hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to today
we're gonna look at a film by Dom Blu
damn it how come he keeps turning up
here I mean it's not like the guy isn't
a good director he started to some great
movies like Land Before Time and
americantale and the secret of NIMH one
of my all-time favorite films but much
like Schwarzenegger for every good film
he's made he's also made of bad and not
only are they bad they're weird
unbelievably weird case in point the
pebble in the paint but if you took a
combination of nyquil and vicodin and
decide to watch happy feet for an hour
this is probably what you'd see yet
another strange and often clumsily anime
a film that wants to look nice as
opposed to make any logical sense it's
weird it's floppy I have 20 minutes to
wait so let's take a look there is a
charming tradition observed by the
Adelie penguins okay which British chick
will have little to no character outside
of narrating is this Jenny Wallace who's
that oh the woman from Oliver neat so
she talks about how penguins use a
pebble to give to their loved ones as a
mating ritual which starts off our tail
of the pebble in the penguin as the
story book explains though I mean as the
song book explains apparently the film
is so cheap it couldn't afford a story
book so I've resorted to the sheet music
instead
[Music]
so as the credits roll we get a unique
but still very strange opening it's the
penguin swimming and singing through the
sheet music of the movie which looks
nice but what the hell's the point of it
are they gonna go tap-dancing through
the script next marking off all the bad
lines they don't like the script would
only be a page long if they did that
[Music]
[Applause]
by the way is it me or does this sound
like the meeting song from the great
Muppet Caper
ha
[Music]
hat songwriter wrote this anyway that
explains a lot from the brilliant mind
who brought you married the mole in fact
that's probably how Manilow agreed to do
this bill he's sick and tired of people
saying his kid songs are unoriginal so
he shouted you show that by music notes
everything there you don't see I really
wrote this shit should be that in Fort
Marina if you don't care about the
pebble how will you choose
so our narrator finally starts to
introduce us to our characters of all
the Penguins in all the world she walks
into mine the most romantic was huge so
this is Hubie played by Martin Short
he's in love with a female penguin named
marina play Miami golden they make
awkward small talk that's supposed to
represent a relationship as a evil
penguin named Drake played by Tim Curry
watches over them marina doesn't know it
yet but she's going to be my wife well I
didn't get these pink roids for nothing
you know
so as they sit on top of that thing from
The Nightmare Before Christmas they
start to sing a song so forced to
contrive they would make it into a Teddy
Ruxpin cartoon sometimes I wonder what
why don't you figure out what that lyric
means first it's like saying I want to
figure out what the sound smell like
where was I
choosing uh is that show car trying to
choke her I don't think it's nonsense at
all even if you are a bit Rocky
the Rookery buzzed with excitement all
the bachelors took to the beaches to
find their engagement peppers you know
it's a shame this came out when it did
because I could so easily see Morgan
Freeman narrating all this here we see
the penguin tried desperately to get a
lot his antics fall short too
underwritten slapstick and heavily
confused Jaime thus he will not find a
mate he will spend the rest of his years
knowing that his firm will never carry
out star light star bright first star I
see tonight wish I may wish I might have
the wish I wish tonight thankfully the
last Son of Krypton is sent to earth as
hubby plans to use one of the scorching
hot rocks that doesn't seem to burn him
at all as a pebble for marina but
unfortunately Drake catches him before
he can steer I hear you want to be a big
ladies man boy Tim Curry's American
accent is almost as good as his Romanian
accent isn't it free now of the chains
of Ceausescu traveling the world doing
good is it wrong to say the muscle-bound
penguin sounds more credible Wow no hope
you can swim well he is a penguin
so well in the water he comes across the
world's frigging largest seal and don't
think this means that the Penguins are
just small not only see them compared to
the size of humans the regular size this
seal must have been like a radioactive
mutation experiment at sea one so
because of the storm and the seal I
guess he can't swim begged so we cut to
him in a cage hi when did that happen
when he comes across a bunch of other
penguins who also somehow knitted their
own clothes if none of the grain in
doors do people talk anymore you can buy
a pack of Skittles and it will result in
a musical number also has anybody
noticed they're out of their frigging
cages just leave stop torturing us with
metallo's rejected commercial jingles
just then another penguin is throwing to
the seller names rock played by James
Belushi
who's with me who's for bustin out here
bunch of bird brains seal bait get me
outta here
so Hubie for his magic space pebble can
see what's going on back home I want you
to be my mate Drake I love humans I
deeply sympathize dude the scene is so
blurry you could host a Barbara Walters
special in it remember you must choose a
mate before the full moon mating
ceremony or be banished
really they had to make a law about that
was there really some penguin who was
just refusing to mate so they had to
create a law to enforce it sometimes I
don't want to know about the animal
kingdom sir take me with you you talking
to me
yes I am don't call me sir Tommy Rocko
Sookie p.m. Rocko work out a plan to get
themselves off the ship you're gonna be
Gordon fisherman's bitch Dixon like it
[Music]
this started getting the Thailand ship
estas
so as they perform penguin Amistad they
get off the ship and swim for some
Hawaiian island you're lost and I'm
looking at a dead penguin getting back
to Marina is all that matters to me
I mean Rocco look I dream about her
night and day I see your face when I
suppose my eyes look I do things when
that happens things that my penguin
Minister says makes baby cheese's try
so while Rocco refuses to help Hubie by
the way hi unfinished fire QB gets Rocco
to admit when he's really been looking
for I got something what is it you're
looking at it
[Music]
you wanna bonk a seagull you you wanna
fight
don't laugh Rocco just accept no I'm
gonna fly fly so he convinces Rocco then
he knows a penguin named Waldo
that's not photograph who can help show
them how to fly if he gets him back home
[Music]
meanwhile at Franken berries house we
see Drake continues to try and put the
moves on Marita no oh I get it
you're joking don't make me laugh the
endless musical of West ice story can
fucking continue
is it weird to say that during this song
all I'm thinking about is why penguins
have hands don't move so we come back to
our heroes who found a very odd
island of woman as Hubie emits a sad
secret that he's been keeping from Rocko
I Rocko there's something you should
know your modern life it's no longer in
reruns
Waldo isn't real but I needed you to
show me the way home I didn't think
you'd do it might just as next you'll be
telling me if the cake is a lie to me
so because they laughed for no apparent
reason I guess that means they're
friends again makes sense to me
meanwhile back at home we find that
musical numbers don't need to have a
point or lead in anymore
no think you just start and come out of
nowhere
[Music]
she's sad next we get yet another
chasing with the world's largest seal
which seems to be down Bluths new
underwater cats
[Music]
what's taking that seal so long anyway
is he just enjoying his time shitting
around with them I know what you're
thinking did he fire six shots or only
five
you've got to ask yourself one question
do I feel lucky well do you punk
so they swim swim swim around until they
finally outrun the Beast which results
in yet another argument you risk your
life to get back to that chick and give
her that blasted pebble you're crazy
you're insane
yeah amazing
Muraki really seems to mood swing to the
convenience of the plot doesn't he get
out of my face I didn't say nothing like
that do like me I don't like any bow I
guess this means we put our differences
on ice alright I'll take that joke I'll
even laugh at it ha ha ha please not
another one
[Music]
we'll find our way to stormy weather if
you excuse me I feel rather dirty I'm
gonna take a bath
[Music]
so if you're still alive after your
brush with death the painless catch a
ride on yet another shit huh they keep
finding all these ships but they run
into a rather hungry bunch of whales
looking for some penguin shop
so after the whales finally piss off we
see that Rocco apparently got killed in
the process of course he did
Rocco
well after that 100% not fake out we see
that Drake his kidnapper inna to force
her to be his bride got your Bootsy
flippers off my girl
man tits away
[Music]
well yeah what do you think was gonna
happen dumbass I didn't come fees
thousand miles and lose my best buddy to
be stopped by the likes of you
I came to lose my virginity come on so
he defeats Drake and oh what a surprise
Rocko isn't dead yeah you really had me
going there movie good one no I
conveniently shipped the location
- that was a pretty harsh death I mean
just because you don't show blunt it
doesn't mean it's not gruesome in fact
let's put some blood in that scene and
see how it looks
yeah disturbing
yeah what they don't show you is the
angle he's really going no of course
Rocco can't fly now breaking the laws of
nature and gravity because he ate a
fairy I don't know but it seems to have
saved the day
so Marina and hubby get together they
fly into the sunset and they all wear
Santa hats because yeah I guess this was
a Christmas Phil that's the pebble on
the penguin so today a bit work well how
do I put this out of all the bad Don
Bluth movies this one is probably the
least bad it almost works the voice
acting is not bad and while the
animation can be sloppy it's still down
Bluth animation which is always
impressive it just gets lost in a
generic story and those few really weird
turns that either work to blues
advantage or don't and in this case they
don't it's not really a film I'd
recommend for kids as there's much
better films to show them but as is it's
not terrible and if a kid really wanted
to see it I guess there'd be no harm and
besides it's just false advertising when
I hear the title the pebble in the
penguin this is what I expect to see now
that would have been an interesting
crossover I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have
[Music]
and maybe I wonder what the collars mean